hey everyone it's Mike from orflows here
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you could join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about you know the
pluses and minuses of trading a
time-based chart versus something like a
range based chart you know because this
is a question that I get quite often I
see it come up in the comments you know
which is a better chart to trade and you
know I want to spend some time you know
sort of going through the differences
and again you know when it comes down to
choosing your chart Style it it is
really a personal preference I mean I
could make recommendations on what
um you know I think is a good chart to
trade in terms of you know time based or
volume based or tick based or range
based and at the end of the day you're
the one that's got to trade it you're
the one that's got to pull the trigger
on trade you're the one that has to
manage the risk so before I jump in you
know if you've been enjoying these
videos be sure to subscribe to the
channel click the notification Bell so
you don't miss a new upload when it
comes out and if you find today's video
helpful be sure to hit the like button
for me and if you can leave a comment
sharing your biggest takeaway out of
appreciate that you know I love hearing
your feedback your support does go a
long way in helping me motivate me
rather you know creating more content
just like this so if you're getting
value from this channel be sure to
subscribe now let's go ahead and get
started on today's topic all right so
time base versus Range base now you know
especially when you're looking at a
footprint chart when you're looking at
volume right the way you format your
chart is going to make a difference in
what you're seeing on the screen okay so
this is a range based chart this is a
Time based chart this is the euro
currency right I chose the euro currency
because it's it is a a market that I've
go back and forth using a Time base
chart and a range base chart I keep
actually both of them open I'm going to
talk about some of the the benefits of
using it now you know when people use a
range based chart right this is an eight
range chart now again what's the most
what's the optimal range that you're
going to use for a market well I think
it depends on the market you're trading
you know I I find an eight range chart
in uh Euro currency and most currencies
to be fine you know some people like six
some people like 10. it really comes
down to
um you know how you're going to manage
your risk because it's one of those
things where
you know when you're using a range bar
and you're trading breakouts right
you're going to have an idea of where
your support and resistance is based off
of you know chart structure okay now
Traders will argue that a range-based
chart removes noise from the market
right because it's going to filter out
non-meaningful price movements and help
you just focus on significant price
action
okay well at the same time you know they
then they argue that on a one minute
chart
it includes all these minor price
movements right rather than filtering
out the noise which you know ideally you
know you do want to filter out noise but
really what is noise noise is the market
facilitating trade it's what the market
does and
when Traders think of noise right that
often leads to over trading and with a
time-based chart right the bar just
closes it's based on time does based on
anything else you know how a bar forms
60 seconds all right if it's a one
minute chart 30 seconds if it's a 30
minute chart while a range based chart
you know when it breaks out of that
range then it's going to form a new bar
right it's going to be a fixed range on
each bar so you know that you know each
bar is a certain amount of ticks right
on the on the eight range chart it's
going to be nine ticks but
does that is it going to change your
form of analysis no but it's going to
give you sort of different entries and
exits so for example right this is a
high on Friday right Friday morning 9 17
in the euro currency on a range-based
chart what do I see up here that's
bearish well I see the bearish Prominent
Point of control right I see Supply
coming into the market in the order flow
right it slanted a bit heavier
on the offer side on what actually
traded right the Delta is positive so I
know that there's got Delta 137 so I
know there's a 137 contracts more traded
on the offer than on the bid
so that's assigned to me of Supply
coming into the market you know I've got
the value area you know value areas in
the middle of the bar which is where
you'd expect it to be
I got the two buying imbalances and you
know I got that big wick up there candle
closes you know on its low next candle
opens up
similar thing now I don't have a bearish
prime opponent control coming in here
but I've got the value area up near the
top of the bar again I got some
aggressive selling coming in so it's
bearish you know at this High okay now
does that mean that what I'm seeing on
the one minute chart so the one minute
chart is basically these two bars that
I'm looking at here and here
is taking place in this one minute bar I
still got now here the difference is now
I have a Divergence
okay because I have negative Delta on
the one minute I'm sorry on the Range
base chart
I had positive Delta still okay so that
that's one of the differences I still
got the bearish prime opponent control
I've got one buying imbalance in here
and I still got my aggressive selling
taking place here right then the next
bar I got the bearish ratio and it's
starting to trade down obviously a lot
of aggressive selling taking place in
this bar got one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven selling
imbalances in this bar so I know it's
quite strong already and again bearish
bar here at the High second bar also
bearish bar and again that's coming in
you know these two bars you know goes
from 53 down to basically 108 29 108 30
here okay so obviously the bar at the
high is bearish next bar is also bearish
on
on the Range base chart obviously
bearish bar on the high follows up with
the bearish bar and you're seeing sort
of it get split up in here this
these from about this price level in the
bar 108 29 and a half up to about here
is one bar on the minute base chart okay
but here on the Range base chart it's
split up now
can you get in earlier well of course
you can right you're seeing already the
bearish development come in here because
it's split up over two bars and
if you're trading the range base chart
right 9 17 28 9 17 39 these two bars
very bearish if you're trading the rain
the minute base chart you know you're
not getting in potentially until 9 19.
so you're getting in a bit a little bit
later maybe a minute later
than on the Range base chart but you're
still seeing a lot of the same things
you know this is the thing that I've
noticed with a lot of Traders is
yeah I see it with a certain group of
Traders actually you know they always
talk about
um you know you got to look at the
higher time frame higher time frame
higher time frame
but the problem is if you're using order
flow
the best way to use it is as soon as you
see it happening in the market right so
that if you're using a range-based chart
you're seeing it right up in here in
this bar
maybe even this bar okay maybe you're
not convinced right now at this high but
after the second bar you should already
be convinced you should be looking to
get short at 108.45
okay
45 is right here if you're on a
range-based chart or sorry A Time base
chart
you might not be getting short until
about 108.40 so you know you're giving
up about five full ticks or euro
currency trades in half ticks
excuse me
so
that's one of the benefits you know of
using a range-based chart but one of the
things you've got to remember on a time
on a range based chart is if a market is
in fast Market mode okay now obviously
if you see stuff like this on a
footprint markets fast Market mode the
software ninjatrader can't handle the
data that's coming out because it's just
coming out like a fire hose like water
and a fire hose is just overwhelming and
you get some weird looking footprint
just like that
okay
now here right if you can't recognize
this is for me one of the drawbacks of
range-based strikes because I used to
use range based charts a lot you know
I'll say almost exclusively
um in the past when markets were a bit
calmer right obviously when covid hit
the markets back in 2020 markets went in
you know vix was so high markets were in
berserko mode
um you know big ranges on you know
big ranges on on a time-based chart but
on a range-based chart you could imagine
so look at this this is 903
okay this is 902 in 55 seconds
903-007 09
14. So within
20 seconds you know we rallied from 12
and a half all the way up and this is 15
here you know all the way up to 32 and a
half 20 ticks right and it's moving very
fast and this is the problem right in
markets that are have a lot of
volatility and they're moving around
very quickly
um you can get those big jumpsuit oh my
gosh I got something bullish here by the
time you know it's easy to look back on
a chart and say oh yeah this was very
bullish here this bar and I'm going to
get long right here well reality is you
have that bullish information coming in
here by the time your order gets filled
right if it's a market order you're
probably filled up here
27 you're not getting it at 18 for sure
because it's just you know it just by
time the order hits the market Market's
already moved by the time you hit click
Market's already up here that's one of
the drawbacks of a range-based chart in
the sense of thinking that you know in a
fast moving Market your fill is going to
be you know instant instantaneous right
look at this this is 903 and 07 seconds
this bar closes in two seconds later so
even if you're like oh this is
I get long here by time you click Market
buy it's filled up here at 31 all right
not at 25 and a half
so you know that was to me one of the
drawbacks when a market has a lot of
volatility and is moving quickly
then that's going to happen right
perfect example trade NASDAQ trade
mnq doesn't matter what type of chart
click market look at the price of where
the market is Trading
when you click Buy
Market
to the time you get your fill
sometimes it could be you know
three four five six ticks worse than
You're Expecting that's slippage okay
but not again not every Market is going
to exhibit slippage you know in sort of
normal you know markets that don't have
a lot of
um
you know I'll say volatility but you
know markets that move nice and slow you
know like a 10-year
note okay
um uh 10 years I I look at treasuries
you know 10 years fives
bonds Ultra bonds Ultra tense I use a
four range chart exclusively I can't
trade a time-based chart and I'll talk
about it why in a second but if you're
using a range based chart
like this type of market right if you
click buy one at the market you're
filled basically at the offer it doesn't
you know the bid offer is extremely
thick extremely strong so if you buy you
know there's always there's a hundred
there's hundreds or even thousands on
the bid in the offer that it's got that
liquidity a market like NQ mnq it
doesn't have that type of liquidity so
you're going to experience that slippage
um
and again you know depending on which
Market you're Trading
is going to determine what size range
based chart you want to use so for
example I had something on my mind I
just wanted to cover really quick
I can't think of it I can't remember
sorry if it comes back I'll I'll throw
it in there if oh yeah so why I you know
why I use range based charts on
slow moving markets that have a lot of
volume like treasuries like 10 years
um compare this chart
okay let me just get the uh
the time-based chart here right I'll
even go well a five minute chart is
going to be a little bit better here
see
five minute chart in treasuries okay you
do get the movement so imagine right if
this was uh you know I don't know
the second chart here
okay like that one minute
okay
you're not going to get much trading the
bid or the offer right you'd have to
you know that's 60 seconds
um you know obviously you're not gonna
go less than that if you're trading a
two minute chart
you know sometimes you know where people
or fixate you know people you know
people trade a lot of different types of
chart a two minute chart is a little bit
better
in the sense of at least now you have
some price movements you know a one
minute chart
not so much you know a three minute
chart a little bit better
right you're getting some price
movements but if it's on a quiet market
right where it's just trading basically
the bid and the offer like here you're
not going to get much you'll see well
you got a selling imbalance here okay
but the only reason you gotta selling a
balance because it traded 12 here if it
got through right here it was 1075
trading at 12 but nothing traded because
it was 12 offered but it was 11 and a
half bit if one contract traded here at
11 and a half then I'd have a buying a
balance here and uh selling a balance
there just like here right
one two two six four Lots here okay so
that's an imbalance it's hard to really
um get much in the sense of what is
happening in the market on slow moving
markets that trade a lot of volume on a
time-based chart or even let me just
rephrase that it's hard to get a lot of
information in the order flow
on markets that don't move very much on
a time-based chart if you were to look
at you know maybe it was
take a look at the
he right Ichi is lean Hogs people a lot
of people don't trade lean Hogs but just
to give you an example well Friday
though we did have some nice uh
price movement but if you go back
the loop sold off but sort of on a
normal trading day right it kind of
looks like this
for the most part I mean you do get bars
that sort of come in you know with
bigger ranges but this is a great Market
to trade order Flow by the way
um it's not as sexy as the e-minis but
um it is nice versus if you were to look
at this Mark that hog market on a range
based chart okay
for a lot of Traders it's a little bit
easier to grasp because bars now are
consistent as opposed to
you know bar with two price levels three
price levels and all of a sudden about
10 price levels then it contracts two
price levels one price level two price
levels right so if you're using a range
based chart you know it's all it's
pretty consistent okay obviously the
volumes are going to be different if the
market is moving fast like it did on
Friday okay you know here we gotta drop
but it's still relatively so all right
let's take this range-based chart is you
know at times about a 30 second chart
so there are pluses and minuses to
trading uh range-based charts as opposed
to time-based charts
um
you know for for some traders that they
they tell me it preserves their sanity
because there's less choppiness and
noise they find on range charts and as a
result that prevents you know over
trading and and
emotional trading right emotional
Capital
um so at the end of the day really it
just comes down to what you're
comfortable with right I said
I I trade both I look at both
um
it's really a personal decision you know
it's one of those things about making
putting the chart up on your screen
that's going to help you understand the
markets the most
okay so there's no point putting things
on your screen that
you know a chart rather on your screen
that isn't helpful to you in your
trading right you want to have the most
useful chart that's going to help you
understand the market it's going to help
you understand what you're looking at
and more importantly what you're Trading
so anyway guys I hope you guys got
something decent out of this video that
wraps up this video on Range versus
time-based charts I hope you enjoyed
this video
and again if you haven't already
subscribe be sure to subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you guys on the
next video bye-bye